faye read an article that said 26 of
americans can speak more than one
language she was curious if this figure
was higher in her city so she tested her
null hypothesis that the proportion in
her city is the same as all americans 26
her alternative hypothesis is it's
actually greater than 26 percent where p
represents the proportion of people in
her city that can speak more than one
language she found that 40 of 120 people
sampled could speak more than one
language so what's going on is here's
the population of her city she took a
sample her sample size is
120 and then she calculates her sample
proportion
which is 40
out of 120
and this is going to be equal to 1 3
which is approximately equal to
0.33
and then she calculates the test
statistic for these results was z is
approximately equal to 1.83
we count we do this in other videos but
just as a reminder of how she gets this
she's really trying to say well how many
standard deviations above the assumed
proportion remember when we're doing the
significance test we're assuming that
the null hypothesis is true and then we
figure out well what's the probability
of getting something at least this
extreme or this extreme or more and then
if it's below a threshold then we would
reject the null hypothesis which would
suggest the alternative but that's what
the z statistic is is well how many
standard deviations above the assumed
proportion is that so the z statistic
and we did this in previous videos you
would find the difference between this
what we got for our sample our sample
proportion and the assumed true
proportion so 0.33 minus 0.26
all of that over
the standard deviation of the sampling
distribution of the sample proportions
and we've seen that in previous videos
that is just going to be the assumed
proportion so it would be just this it'd
be the assumed population proportion
times 1 minus the assumed population
proportion over n
in this particular situation that would
be
0.26
times 1 minus 0.26
all of that over our n that's our sample
size 120
and if you calculate this this should
give us approximately
1.83 so they did all of that for us
and they say assuming that the necessary
conditions are met they're talking about
the necessary conditions to assume that
the sampling distribution of the sample
proportions is roughly normal and that's
the random condition the normal
condition the independence condition
that we have talked about in the past
what is the approximate p-value well
this p-value this is the p-value
would be equal to the probability of in
a normal distribution we're assuming
that the sampling distribution is normal
because we met the necessary conditions
so in a normal distribution what is the
probability of getting a z greater than
or equal to 1.83 so to help us visualize
this imagine let's visualize what the
sampling distribution would look like
we're assuming it is
roughly normal the mean of the sampling
distribution right over here would be
the assumed population proportion so
that would be p not when we put that
little zero there that means the assumed
population proportion from the null
hypothesis and that's
0.26 and this result that we got from
our sample is 1.83 standard deviations
above
the mean of the sampling distribution so
1.83
so that would be 1.83
standard deviations and so we want to do
this probability is this area under our
normal curve right over here so now
let's get our z table
so notice this z table gives us the area
to the left of a certain z value we
wanted it to the right of a certain z
value but a normal distribution is
symmetric so instead of saying anything
greater than or equal to 1.83 standard
deviations above the mean we could say
anything less than or equal to 1.83
standard deviations below the mean so
this is what negative 1.83
and so we could look at that on this z
table right over here
negative
one let me
negative one point eight
three
is this
right over here so
0.0336
so there we have it
so this is approximately
0.0 3
or a little over three percent or a
little less than four percent and so
what faye would then do is compare that
to the significance level that she
should have set before conducting this
significance test and so if her
significance level was say five percent
well then in that situation since this
is lower than that significance level it
would she would be able to reject the
null hypothesis she would say hey the
probability of getting this result
assuming that the null hypothesis is
true is below my threshold it's quite
low and so i'll will reject it and it
would suggest the alternative however if
her significance level was lower than
this for whatever reason if she had say
a one percent significance level then
she would fail to reject the null
hypothesis